uh will kathy know uh this lady yes
i feel like i do precious
no
well that was awkward maybe i was
confused kathy hilton mistaking pop icon
lizzo for actress gabaree citabay in a
game testing her knowledge of famous
faces on bravo's watch what happens live
uh that is liz she is precious though
that's like what i call her lizzo is
precious to me yes
no lizzo is precious
now we know the real housewives of
beverly hills star doesn't have the best
eyesight
[Applause]
how are you wait i thought you were kyle
mistaking you
for her sister
yes you're right not just kyle her
sister
a family member a family member even
though she claims i don't forget faces
i don't know i think this might be our
first time meeting familiar but you know
my eyes you never know i'm thinking well
i don't think we met i think i would
remember but shoot i could be wrong you
know so it was we might have met she
might be right i might be wrong who
knows but so far both lizzo and gabby
seem unbothered by the slip up gabby
hasn't responded on social media while
lizzo dumped some hot girl summer pics
to the gram the morning after the mishap
i'm feeling good as hell
and we're sure kathy's focused on other
things
i saw her just so angry i had locked
myself in the bedroom
i had said some things out of
frustration
that i was feeling personally how could
you say those things you know when you
start to get cranky or whatever so i
said some things
that
i should not have said they were off
camera and i thought it was i'm leaving
i am being pissed off kathy was [ __ ]
raging i don't even know who that person
was yeah the back half of season 12
promises to be a rocky one for the
reality star if i can be torn apart
earrings and widows kathy has to own
hers too
i just want to know where that hatred
comes from you can be very unkind too
how do you feel about lisa brenner then
inserting herself into the sister
dynamic there i think that she um
yeah i think that she
cares about
you know a lot about kyle and i i think
that she cares about me and i think she
just wanted to help out i mean i don't
know did you appreciate the help or not
i don't know we'll have to see we'll
have to see how it's edited how the
whole thing
you know
[Music]